welcome to this video playing agro koi
yeah who is that I have no idea and I've
good score four and a half out of five
that's good the flag doesn't help he's
not from Guam very likely okay so he's
taking once you form Queens gambit
accepted yeah this line with Bishop g4
is not bad interesting interesting
option but underestimated line maybe
black has got fairly fairly solid
position one idea for wide is to go g4
quickly and let's do that now gaining
the bishop pair and funny idea is that
white quite often plays Bishop everyone
what really um Bishop f1 but now that's
not going to happen c5 looks strange
weakening the light squares so much but
ok let's see let's say I can go d 5 here
d 5 has got be 5 which might be okay i
also have g5 first and then d 5 maybe
that i have a certain dish of some kind
of feeling like I had this before
okay so i can tip here let's it's not
very convincing I can't do this in tikz
5 which pretty much means a pawn but
we're thinking maybe I have something
better but ok upon is a pawn why not
take it Queen g 525 it's really ok him
I'm just winning that pawn for nothing
basically ok um night Queen 794 he's got
Bishop before check just about yeah I
wonder if I should just trade Queens or
not like with Queenie forward prolly m94
still should before still could be good
it's pretty it's pretty forcing way to
play check I mean this is a nice
centralized position here so I'm why not
okay look the eighth
i came i can go rook rook team won but
he's got 96 and then still whoop dee aid
so it was probably not necessary this
this kind of this kind of play well I
should have played something something
simpler would be would have been much
easier probably so what to do yeah units
let's um just keep that night protected
yeah sure man oh that was really bad i
shoulda played sure played something
simple he was just a pawn down with the
bad position and here it's kind of
unclear with my my king only two and so
on I mean maybe i can i can just attack
him here but ok let's do that let's do
that it tries to make some sense out of
out of my plane
but that show just plain ol moves even
Queenie for was good just trade queens
with the polyp
Jim what is he going to do just take on
age five probably know what is he doing
a group t3 coming let's tidy
well came and I go age 6 Luke these
three I can take gee I cannot take just
seven but all but two up to three I have
Queenie for okay let's do that hmm I was
a totally unnecessary way to play but ok
it's a funny position at least okay i
was thinking okay that take on g7 look
be three Knight f6 check I mean this is
let's at least a draw that's funny
enough but can I go Queen 84 and we have
no time it's important to note and
absolutely no time but ok the Queen
holiday from a4 might actually swing
over to h4 so maybe that it's not so bad
I mean age takes g7 is a pretty big big
threat what is he doing Roxy form and
then I'm definitely taking this out it's
night-night f6 is pretty devastating
then ok I think I can just take here why
not ok 496 is just winning so let's
let's take on g7 ok for Knight f6 King
g7 rook h7 is made and look a 49 f6
Queen takes g takes is made on h8 cannot
prevent it
I asked there was something else and
then don't see what what is going to do
hmm funny night d 7 I can take the room
what is he doing could be just winning
avoid this position as weird as it is
and night time morning neither six
anyway I'm threatening threatening mate
Brooke age seven king bag check and Ruby
g8 made as a threat the rook c4 move
weakened the eighth-ranked that was the
problem
well that sets it I don't see a defense
black resigned yeah funny yeah really
funny I mean maybe I could have even
taken the bishop but Lucy too okay and
the computer is not agreeing it says
route 28 is still a movie 'um k okay now
now now it gives a wide win but it's
apparently not so simple okay let's
let's go back a little bit what was I
mean the c5 is a strange move you should
try to keep the position closed but okay
I took it and then went here okay the
computer still thinks this is kind of
okay after 97 but after this it looks
weird right okay Bishop jigs and turn
the computer store things this is not
like terrible for black which is
surprising I really don't see the
compensation where's the compensation
for the pond if I play I mean if I don't
play what I did and it's this thing but
let's say like this this and I know long
castles or Queenie form I don't really
see where the compensation is but ok I
tried this and King it too and this is
just a rubbish idea Bishop to tab2 is
also better but now my king is just yeah
my king is just not secure this is much
better even now I mean I'm not lost or
anything but it was totally unnecessary
to to get into this kind of yeah an
ammonius position and KF three and this
and the computer loves black which is no
surprise but somehow it got it got
trickier again at night if
yeah account gives a black win let's see
how rooks eh yeah and its ass black wins
how exactly after age six computer wants
to play rook c4 and gives a black win
okay just what is the the point actually
I don't I don't get it yet it just wants
to check the night or a chick here yeah
it takes the night after this Queen g5
is winning uh-huh because of Queen g
2-20 is pretty high oh no it finds a
mate actually so I made it like that so
Roxy for was really really good move him
after this ok this is given as a draw by
the engine yeah I saw that yeah well I
saw that this is a draw check check
check check but I wanted to wanted to
try to continue to play and this is
apparently not working due to Queen to
c7 for Quincy to check now and after
this it seems I'm winning but not in a
trivial they truly away
yeah root p8 is what he has to do and
then before as the the engine move for
Bishop b2 and wide wins but very very
difficult very very difficult okay well
thanks for watching